Khloe Kardashian opens up about Rob
Kardashian's weight gain you feel like
trapped in your own body and you know
and I feel that way for my brother
[Music]
in a preview for the reality star show
revenge body the 33 year old brings up
her brothers struggles with the scale
while comforting married couple Chad and
Alison I don't feel like a beautiful
woman and my husband doesn't feel like a
strong man I know how you feel you feel
like trapped in your own body and you
know and I feel that way for my brother
who you know has gained a lot of weight
it's debilitating meanwhile Alison's
husband opens up about his inability to
gain weight and Chloe explains that her
little sister Kendall Jenner has been
skinny shamed - my sister Kendall when
she was growing up she was very skinny
and she used to get bullied all the time
for being too skinny and I think body
shaming of any two kind kind is still
bullying and not acceptable the Keeping
Up with the Kardashians star has also
faced body shaming over the years and
was most recently slammed on social
media by some of her followers for
working out while pregnant that's
bizarre to me and you would think people
would be happy that I'm staying healthy
and fit and my doctor wants me to
workout every day if I could so I'm
doing doctor's orders and I feel good
[Music]